Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller asking about could there be
a millennial exodus coming? Listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. So do you
think it's reasonable to say that
maybe in the next few years, maybe up to ten
years, we could experience some sort of exodus
of young people, say, you know, let's say 1922, 19
or 20 years old, maybe early thirties. You know,
young professionals who just saw.
Speaker 1: This, by the way,
I don't think a 19 year old now is a millennial,
but that doesn't even matter. Doesn't even
matter. We're still taking the question.
Speaker 4: Reached due to politics in
this country. So many issues going on and
they may want to just live somewhere else.
Do you think that that's really going to be a
possible thing? And what do you think most of
those young people will go?
Also for the previous caller,
Einstein Bagels. That's that's the place to go.
Speaker 1: Okay. I don't know about the Einstein
Bagels thing. So here's the deal.
There is no question that there
are young millennials and then, you know, the
next generation after that, I guess that's Gen Z
who are very displeased. Generally speaking,
with the stagnant wage, student loan debt,
right wing politics, industrial complex. They're
not feeling good about it, and many of them
would love to opt out in different ways. Now,
opting out might be accepting a sort of more
simple rural life rather than the typical graduate
from college and then move to or stay in a big
city. That might be one element of it. But the
reality is most people are going to need to work,
and it's pretty difficult to move to most other
countries that people would want to go to. I mean,
some of the easier countries to move to are
countries that are not necessarily high on
the list of places people want to move to. I mean,
there are there are countries listen, Argentina,
where I was born. It's relatively easy to move
to Argentina and eventually find legal status.
You can go if you eventually are able to get
employment or start attending school. You
are given a path to legalization takes years, but
you can just sort of do it. But the economy is a
shambles. And so why would why would anybody
want to do it doesn't really make any sense.
So while I think the idea is is an accurate
one, there's lots of people, young millennials,
Gen Z, who would love to say, I'm packing it up,
I'm going to do something completely different
unless you want to, you know, teach English
somewhere or join the Peace Corps. Sometimes
these are the ways to do it. It's pretty hard to
move to a lot of the places people would want to
to move to. And so for that particular reason,
I don't think it's going to be a big thing.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
The Senate Republicans are now backtracking
after a huge firestorm over the veterans
bill. Eastern Kentucky flooding has now caused
37 deaths and there is more rain in the forecast.
What is going on? What is the infrastructure
situation that is leading to these deaths? And
also, we have learned that the Sandy Hook parents,
who are the plaintiffs in the Alex Jones
defamation case due to safety concerns,
they have been isolated with security during
this wacky Alex Jones trial. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign up
at join Packman dot com to get instant access.